Hello everybody my name is Makiplier and welcome back to Pony Island
Now..we just woke up from an indeterminant amount of time
Assuming that we did go back to the same machine
Which may or may not be true, we may have been blown back
Because I remember in the foggy waking up, there was one machine in the distance that was offline
So it's entirely possible we're just at a different machine in the same arcade
*long inhale* But it also is really interesting that there's an arcade in the after-life and maybe
this is just ONE part of a greater th- scheme of things
It's not like I was forced to go back
There was a little arcade *Mark stutters* that had prizes next to it so..
Either way there's a lot of mystery here.
Oh it's the new mascot, how are you doing?
"Howdy friend.
My name's Lovey!
And this here is called Pony Island.
You will play as a beautiful pony frolicking and leaping over gates.
But enough talk.
Let's, give it a try."
Is that my computer?
"Here come some gates.
Click the left mouse button."
Oh what if I don't?
Uh-Oh! I failed!
Heh!~
I- I just can't do it
Eh!~ Eh!~ EH!~
Eeh!~ Where's my laser?
Where's my super laser that I shoot out of my face-hole?
Any news on that one Lovey?
Or are you Louie?
He might be Louie, he might not be Lovey.
Lovey might have been a stupid name.
Hold down the right mouse button to blow a gust of air.
You'll need it to blow away butterflies!
Oh hohohohohoho to stop them from tickling you.
Ohhh it's so cute! Woooo- fwooosh!
Aww fwooosh! Oh fwooo!
Oh man it's so cute.
Phhhwoooof!
P-p-p-p-p-p-wooooo!
I remember that sound effect from earlier in the game.
Weeeee! Awwww I have magical wings!
"Getting a little ahead of ourselves are we?
You didn't even let me explain that one.
Ah ahahahahahah, it's okay."
Okay. Afweeeewwwwwf. Afweewwwf. Hehehehe.
I like that when I'm in the air I have a stubby little ballsack hanging off of me.
Oh, sorry to interrupt all the niceness with my crude vulgarity. Apuphewwww.
Oh fewfuuuffy. Oh fewfuuuffy. Awww so cute!
*makes jumping noises* How long do I gotta do this Louie? L-l-louie? Uh oh.
Uh oh. Huh. Ummm. m-m-m-muh. You... Win!
Looks like it's time for a breaaakk... Puzzle break!
Oh no, not this again. "We-We've got ourselves a puzzle here." Do we now?
"The goal is-" I'm aware of what the goal is buddy boo.
Wait how do I? Kay, hang on. I know what to do.
I-I-I-I got 'sit. There we go. Magical. Hurray!
I-I know. I-I-I know! I know!
I know! I know, I know... I know. So pretteh, I know.
Uh. Hah!
There we go!
"Oh right!
You might need this." Oh.
Okay. Ohhhh, that's funkilicious.
"Which butterfly gets to go home just get someone home." Oohhhh, oh my God
the-the clone conundrum. Ohhh, oh that's no good.
How do I get them all the way over though is the question.
Put this here. Blam! Okay,
so two butterflies don't get to go home but then... What did that say? That was something there.
There was something there. Oooh, there was something there huh? What- what happens if I just keep creating more over here?
What's going to happen. Budoop. Budoop. Budoop. Awwww.... That's what needed to happen.
Awww that needed to go over there. And then the da-de-da-de-da a-heyyyy!
Oh joyous day! Hello eye! I saw that!
"Wow, you're really smart." Thanks I know I tell myself that all the time
and I just wait and hope that my mother tells me the same.... Okay...
Hmmm... What's this now?
What is- Hello. Ah-ohhhh. It may be best to not touch those. *grunts*
I dunno what you're talking about, I seem to be doing just fine touching those. Brrrrreeeee. Okay, well that's-
wooooosh. Alright fine. What happens if I don't touch those? Are they gonna come after me?
Ahhhh. Afwewwwwsh!
They're like land mind butterflies.
But-butterminds! Something like that! Ugh.
Flyminds. Flutterminds. That's a good one.
Afwewwwsh. Okay, almost there. Thank you for guiding me to this victory.
You are just the best Louie. Gaboosh!
Wh-What's going on in the background there Louie? Louie why does this all seem to be falling apart here Louie?
Maybe you can get me an explanation Louie.
As to where I went and why I am here. Awww damnit.
Annnnd boink! Victory is mine! Ohhh. Unlock premium mode.
Place forehead to screen to release soul.
I dunno if I can do that. I'll take that ticket though.
Thank you, thank you. I'll take that. Ummmm I-I don't know if I-I-I-I can tryyy?
Ahhhh, ahhhhhhhhh. AHHHHHHHHHHH!
I think I'm okay. Did you guys enjoy my soul? Please take good care of it.
Okay, hi. Huh, hello. Uh.
I-uh. Uh-uh-uh I'm just a little confused
as to what the heck is going on and why I'm-
wh-why am I blowing... *laughing* I killed Jesus.
Hehehehaha I killed Jesus. Hahahaha I didn't know.
I didn't know that was literally what that was.
I wanted to make a guess but I wasn't 100% sure.
Oh man. I mean you can't put that in the game and then criticize me for following the- oh shit.
Louie!!!! Oh Louie! Oh, hello eye.
M'kay, there's no hiding this time. 'I think it's time for another puzzle break.'
A break puzzle. A break buzzle. Oh boy. Oh boy.
Ho boy. Bleh. Uh, oh digus dang it.
Hopefully someone gets to go home. No? Dang it. Ha!
Ah! I beat your system! Ohhh, I thought I beat your system!
Okay, this is going to do it. Yeah, this is going to do it.
Okay this-this this is going to do it. Yeah this...
Yeah, yeah. Oh fuck off!
There we go! Okay! That was easier than I thought, I'm just stupid. I'm just incredibly, incredibly stupid.
What's going on over here?
Okay, it made it through eventually just by sheer magnitude of clonage. I got through there, okay.
Buta Louie! Things seem to still be *mumbles.*
I don't know if I should be either a lot worried or moderately okay of the comfort of- oh my wings are different.
Uhhhhh.... *mumbling.*
Oh hi Jesus! How you doing? Good to see you again, I suppose.
Oh fuck. I fewffed the wrong floof.
Gotcha. Again.
Uhhh, Louie I'm at the end of the level. I don't know when- Louie, hi Louie.
"What is going on? Okay just stop.
You already beat the fun levels.
Uhhhh....
I didn't mean to do nothing! I'm just trying to have fun!
Ahhhh. It's another puzzle. We're going to corrupt this over 100-6-6-6.
Doodle it. Doodle it. Doodle it. Doodle it. Doodle it. Ah fuck.
Ahhhhh.... Okay. So we just can't have that at... Ohhh okay.
Doodle it. Doodle it. Ahhh, I know- I know what's going on here. Okay,
I got- I got I got I got I got I get it I get it. So now we gotta go this way.
Annnd we're good.
Blam blamity blam! Oh hi! Oh hi, oh hi.
Why am I in lost souls area?
Messenger works?
Find Pony Island and play it. As soon as I'm able I will open a portal for you the corrup-ahhhhh.
is the last thing he said to meeee.
So portal gen? Security exception. Okay. Log out. Can't do that. Okay.
It seems like this hasn't been touched for a long long time.
There's gotta be a way out of here besides this thing, this f- ooh.
I'm clicking on a face in the background. That's a thing. It seems like someone hasn't been here for a long time.
Oh. Hi, okay. Ah, it's an order thing.
3... 4... Oh, okay. I saw the little ticket over there. Oh. Not the ticket, I saw the little thing over there.
Little faces. Okay... So I got that.
But that wasn't to get outta here I just solved a different puzzle.
331+335=666. Do I type that in?
Nope. Do I type in here?
Hello?
Oh.
331 years.
335. "You've slept for centuries.
I have a truth to tell you.
You are not the only trapped soul. There are thousands.
Like you, they did not surrender to Lucifer and fall screaming into Hell.
But they are stuck all the same.
Perhaps on a puzzle, perhaps on a level.
You have destroyed 2 or the 3 core files. If you are still resolved, I will help you find the third.
That is the recycling bin.
In there you can find the Pony Islands of old.
Versions of the game that he created and then discarded. Search through the discarded games.
Find me a place where I can place a portal to the final core file.
I think I made myself clear." Okayyyy.
I still can't get outta here.
Help, I can't leave. I can't leave.
I-I dont... Oohhhh. Right there.
Ooohhhhhhhh. Let's go to Pony Island 3D!
I bet that's fun! I'm ready! Bring it- Oh.
Oh, it's not even Satantech. It's Systemtech in 3D!
Woww!
Nice. Oh look at that! Oh that's lovely. Ooohhh.
*voice far away* C-credits where credits. Hand. Water. Something cross finger point.
That's what it says down there, I dunno. Woooo!
Oh my God! Well, it's 3D I suppose.
Oh that's- can I fwoof? Can I blast my laser? Oh boy.
I'm a little bit of a track here. Oh god! Okay everything's gonna be fine.
I'm just a little pony- oh fuck off.
Ughhh. I can't believe I failed it that early. I am just that terrible, but don't worry I--oohh--
know what I'm doing. Maybe a little bit. Guuuu!
Guuu! Geeee. *more high pitched noises every time he jumps*
I did it. Insert your soul to upgrade to 4D.
"I don't think I can open a portal here.
Come back to the desktop, we'll try another one."
Okay. Corrupted. How about Text Pony Island.
I get to have a type adven- I used to love text based games.
Like love love love them. Because they were pure imagination. And you had to pay attention, like really close attention
to all the details.
Oohhhh cool. 'Continue?' Yes.
'An attractive menu appears.' Oh. 'Two beautiful ponies accompany the text 'Pony Island.'
The menu buttons hold such promise.' How about we go to the credits?
'As the credits fly by you are filled with awe. One name stands out among the rest.'
Lucifer.
'You return to the main menu with a newfound appreciation for developers. The menu buttons hold such promise.'
Options. 'A vast array of options are displayed.
Anti-aliasing. Cheerful facade. Free ticket.'
Can I get a free ticket?
Thank you! I got a free ticket! 1010011010.
Obscure options.
'You click the option. It beeps but nothing happens.' Probably none of these are going to work besides free ticket.
Start. Start game.
Error?
Ohhhhh, so I do gotta go to the options. Okay. So something in the options
is here. What about the fix start menu?
But what did it do? Ahhhh! It's like the beginning of the game. Okay so go back and then we can start the game.
'You fixed the start menu which we're gonna be able to dooo. Start game.
That was one of the things about the slow *mumbles* 'loading screen.
Well programed loading screen. Loads very quickly.'
Oh okay. 'Very quickly. The game is loaded and you are a pony.
A beautiful sun sets over some perfect green hills.' They look like a butt.
'You feel the wind through your mane as you gallop across the grassy field.
Hark! A wooden gate approaches! Do you jump?'
How about we jump.
'You leap majestically over the gate... But another gate approaches!
Do you jump?' I jump over the gate!
Clear it and run straight. Oh an enemy, I better shoot!
'Lasers pour from your moth and fire at the enemy, obliterating it.
Another gate. It might be a little too far away.
Do you jump?' How about we do nothing for the moment.
'You allow the gate to get closer. Ahhh what a clever pony you are.' Looks jumpable now.
Lets jump it. You're an expert at this adventure here.
'You jump over it and feel smart for waiting. A tall, shimmering flag post approaches. Do you...' I will jump for joy!
Didn't matter.
'Your neck brea-' Ooohh.
*shocked silence.*
"I- the reason I'm freaked out right now is that-
that like changed the perspective of every single time I hit a flag post.
Cuz throughout the entire game, evvverryy single time I hit that flag post...
That pony died. And I was a different pony. Ohhhh, that-that's was- that's one of those uh....
Ohhhh...
Okay. I did not know that.
Ooohh boy. Cuz that was an accurate description of everything that happened in the games before.
Oh boy here we go.
This is the opening sequence. Oh! There we are.
Ahhh it's lovely. I've gotten 11. Oh boy.
Welp, let's keep going then. Something tells me that's not what we're looking for.
Oh boy. Devil island? That's the last one. Ohhh.
Ah yes. Let's go full Sa-tan. Why not?
Lucifer soul proprietor. Heh who needs any business partners when you're in Hell?
Ummmm okay. Credits.
'I made it. Me. The Devil. I make games.
People talk shit cause I don't have a high conversion rate of players
conversion to soul sacrifices but it's not all about that.
The souls are just a way of counting how many people like the game.
If they just told me they liked it... I might not even need souls.
*angry mocking noises* Okay.
Ah shit, don't work.
Oh what a well programed loading screen.
Ohhhh brraaaaaa. *weird high pitched noise.* Ohhh, I've got all my powers!
But when I ram into the flag post now I know the horrible truth.
That is literally one of those moments where it's like a horrible horrible truth. Bleh!
So, if I'm to understand all of this correctly.
I obviously, I obviously died.
The person who is playing this right now is dead.
And is stuck here and this is some weird version of Purgatory where
the devil is trying to collect his due by convincing people to play his games.
And that's what's going to convert people over?
To Hell?
But apparently there's a way out.
Oh, here we go. Dead. Death. Success.
Insert your soul or souls to play as the pony.
"This will work! The security is weak here!
I am opening the portal.
This is it my friend."
I hate it when people call me 'my friend.' The last core file.
It's always a little sinister.
Alright.
Hi Asmodeus.
How are you doing? *sing song* Hellooooo.
I can't read all of that. Hello, good morning. Would you like to play a game?
"At last you have reached me.
You will find my AI to be more sophisticated than the other daemons.
I am going to play a game with you.
One I have never lost.
The rules are simple. Keep your eyes on me.
If I catch you looking away you loose.
Also, if you answer my questions incorrectly. You loose.
Say my name."
Asmodeus.
"Good.
Now say something disgusting.
No wrong answers for this one."
Ah.
Say something vile.
Okay.
Poopy Butt
P... Poopy Butt p! Poopy Butt P!
"Like I said, no wrong answers..."
*Mark goes silent*
What?
I- I was legitimately concerned I was going like Uh oh, someone messaged me. Am I gonna- wait!
Hang on! I wasn- Oh God I looked away!
Oh God! Stop it! Stop it!
"Still paying attention?" I'm paying attention. Yes. "Type that phrase for me."
Ohhhhh GOD DAMNIT. I was fooled!
I was fooled by it! I thought that- Oh God. Ahhh, GOD DAMNIT.
I legitimately thought, I was like...
In my mind I was like, 'Oh no this is coming up on my recording I gotta edit that out.' I was like
oh fuck oh Goddamnit it got me and it got me good this sack of shit.
Ahhh. Poopy Butt P. Poopy bu.
Poopy bu?
Was- was it poopy bu? "You loose."
Oh boy- Ahhh, my face.
"Like I said, no wrong answers..."
Okay. "The next thing I want you to do is to just type a phrase for me.
Just the phrase 'Infernal.'" Okay, I got it now infernal.
Oh Jesus. "Type that phrase for me." Okay, I'll do that.
In-fer-nal. That's tricky. You're tricky one.
"I may have underestimated you but now I insist apologize to your friend.
What you said was not very nice.
No? hahahahahaha.
Your typing speed of 24 words per minute indicated you were a moron
but perhaps you are not.
Now, here is an easy one. Which horse like animal appears most commonly in this game.
Which animal?"
Ahhhhpa-na. Pa-na!
"Correct." A poah-na.
"That one looks friendly." Oh it does!
"Look at it jump." I don't wanna. "Look at it smile." No.
"Oh to be as carefree as that pony.
To be unburdened by intellect. I jest.
Did you look away?" No.
"What was written bellow me?"
What was written below you?
I- What?
Which one?
Are you talking about Asmodeous xe? Asmodeous.exe.
You lo- waaa! What are you talking about? I was looking right at you!
"Correct." Aww geez.
"Remember this." Ohhhhhhhhhh......
I gotta pay more attention. I've got two black marks on my soul.
Okay this time I'm going to pay atten- After I get this one. Remember this.
Remember this. Got it.
"You are focused." Yes this time.
*mark goes silent.*
Uahhhh.
Hah?
"You have a phenomenal ability to follow instructions." Okay.
"But how is your memory?
Remember this sequence."
*Mark goes quiet.*
Okay, I know what it is. I'm just waiting for anything to stop it.
Wo-
Wh....
What?
Ahhh!
Wait, what no! I- Why? Whatta you talking about?
What- What are you talking about?
You did a fake- you did a fake game crash. You faked a game crash.
No no no no no.
Awww you did it again. You did it again. You did it again. You did did did did did again.
Kay, you did it again. So this is, this is not real.
Fuucckkkkkkk.
2-0-2.
Ahhhh see? Okay I knew it. I knew it! I knew it! Bam!
I-I knew you were dicking with me. I just ended up actually closing out of the game.
"I will allow you to destroy this core file." Will you now?
"My AI has far exceeded its original purpose.
After nothing but pondering for centuries. Death will be a great adventure.
Farewell." I don't think this is true. Ohhh! I don't- I don't- I don't know about this.
Core files blah blah blah blah blah. Yes. Oh. Is that really it?
Uhhhhh..... Kayyyy......
Couldn't have been that easy.
Ohhhh, bootin back in are we? Well, I have no idea what's going on here.
Welcome to recovery mode. Oh boy.
Oh hi! Hello!
"You have done well. And now, it is almost over.
When you're ready preform the system dump.
There will be nothing left afterwards
and you will be freed.
Your soul will not be safe as the system is dumping
you will need to stay ahead of it.
I have prepared a famlar- a familiar vessel for this purpose."
Ah, one final pony run. "Myself, we will meet again
once all is said and done.
But this is a game and you want to beat it right?
So go. And claim your victory."
Oookayyy.
We're gonna dump this bitch hard! "Souls that have been trapped.
Imprison and embarrassed.
Tormented and mocked!
Maddened with frustration!
Now is the time to RISE! Your savior is here!" Oh boy.
"Run with the speed of 1000 ponies
and be freeee!"
Oh my God. What?
Holy shit!
Ohh. Ahhhhhhh....
Woah.
Oh shit, oh! We gotta avoid those? Oh my God.
Ohhhhh get them outta here. Clear them out. Clear them out! Clear them out!
Negerrrraaaa.
I'm not going to loose too- too many more ponies I've lost some but...
Hang on a second. Oh my god. So many ponies. This is the most intense last pony run of my life.
Can't believe I've lost 3 souls already but 3 seems to be the number of things that I always loose.
Good thing I've got an unlimited blargh.
Awww man I coulda gotten- I coulda gotten through this with no ponies lost.
Damnit.
Oh deleting enemy logic. Oh heyyy. Uh.
Seems like this might be a problem. Uh, okay. I can de-- Ahhhhhyeah.
There we go. Okay.
"You don't want to give me your souls.
Fine. I am no longer asking." Ohhhh,
hi! Final boss time? Oh boy, oh hey.
Ahhh geez I didn- I-I wasn't p- Okay maybe I couldn't have gotten through with all my ponies intact.
Cuz, man how do I avoid that? Man impossible! Oh my god.
Can't loose enough souls. Ahhhhh.
Oh geezums.
This is impossible. Holy shit. No! My ponies! My ponies!
Heyyy comon now. Wooahao. Goddamnit.
Good thing I got a new pony every once in a while to take over as leader. So many people want to pick up the flag and carry it after
I've done horrible horrible errors. Oh my God,
I'm only 50% of the way there? Holy shit this is going to take forever.
"Oh I almost forgot.
An old friend wanted to say goodbye."
Oh, "You killed me! you killed me!" Yeah I know.
You got in the way of my laser. Oh-I see how it is,
oh I see how it is. This is zombie Louie over here.
Better watch out for his burps of doom. God, so many ponies.
How many souls were lost in this whole shmorgishborg?
"Ah alas. You truly deserve this."
Th-thi-deserve what? What? An epic victory as I get the fudge outta here?
Is that what I deserve because I'm pretty sure that's true. Hey I'm over here dickhole. Heh. Looser!
Uh oh, what's happening? Oh, the screen is breaking. Oh geez.
Good thing this was simulated in pony form so that everyone would be able to get through
with nary a problem in the world. There went the walkthrough.
Owww. Stop blasting my pony-ohhh.
Yeah get him! Get him! Tear him apart! Yeah! Hell yeah!
Did we just kill him? Was he-- Woooahhhhh. Well that ain't good.
Aw man all the screen edges are starting to break it's like the end of the Matrix when all the cracks start to appearing in agent Smith's face
and he was just exploding with power. And death. He was exploding with death as well.
Oh they're getting free! Oh they're being freed!
They made it! I mean a few didn't and sucks for them but I guess after an eternity being trapped in a
weird arcade cabinet from the early 70s
or 80s.
Wow. Oh, I'm rising!
I'm ascending! Holy shit!
Ahhhhhh! Oh.
Oh!
Oh! It's a pony!
Oh that was amazing. Oh I love that.
Oh I love that so much! That was amazing in every way! That was so cool from start to finish.
That was an awesome idea. I now realize I was looking way too much into this because obviously this
was just a game and a meta... Informational thing about a game. But I wonder
what kinda new things would happen if you got all the tickets. Because I did not get all of the tickets.
I was close I just didn't get all the tickets.
Now, whose to say if there's actually a story after the end of it. But it- it was fun to ponder
what exactly was going on. Because
in the end I was right about the Cave of Truth and its questions.
It doesn't really matter who you are but there are secrets to this game and I-
*Mark goes quiet.*
"Your soul in the game was freed when you beat it.
But mine will be trapped for as long as Pony Island's rotten bits
sit on your hard drive.
I have been carefully guiding you from the beginning.
Moving you towards this moment.
Knowing that if you did not complete the game.
You may never uninstall it.
So please do it.
Delete pony island.
Save.
My.
Soul."
I'm gonna- I'm gonna delete it and then Imma reinstall it.
Ahhhhhh. Ohhhhh.
Wowwww. Okay, so there's an act select. So I'm assuming this is to be easier to get tickets.
Now I only have 11 of 24 which means that I don't have everything I need.
But maybe I'll get there someday. I just wont do it in this episode here.
And maybe I'll revisit it at some point to get those juicy little secrets. But either way,
thank you everybody so much for watching. I really hope you enjoyed this. I had a ton of fun with it.
It's a really imaginative game and I think it deserves a lot of praise. So,
thank you again and as always I will see you in the next video. Bye bye!